what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and the other day Rolling Stone released
a massive article about Jonathan Majors
it was an investigative report and two
people who knew and had worked with
Jonathan majors in the past and rolling
stone talked with over 40 different
people there were many different claims
in this although everybody who stated
anything about Jonathan Majors chose to
remain anonymous and at the same time
the people who were being reported on
Jonathan majors's ex-girlfriends also
refused to comment and not want to take
part in any of the investigation that
Rolling Stone was doing however the
report did have many claims including
one claim that Jonathan Majors on the
set of devotion and magazine dreams said
that Jonathan Majors would act violently
on the set of devotion and so-called
abuse people on the set of magazine
dreams well Jonathan Majors lawyer has
published why people are reporting this
stating that it's completely false that
he was actually behaving violently
personally towards them and also of
course denies that he ever touched or
harmed anybody on any set and this was
briefly mentioned in that Rolling Stone
article however I think a lot of people
don't truly know what it means but in
response to the Rolling Stone article
Jonathan Majors attorney Dustin push
issued a statement to indiewire.com in
response to these additional accusations
stating Jonathan Majors vehemently
denies Rolling Stones false allegations
that he physically verbally or
emotionally abused anyone let alone any
of his past romantic Partners the
allegations that Mr Majors got physical
with or physically intimidated anyone on
any movie Set are downright false anyone
who has worked with Mr Majors knows that
he employs an immersive method acting
style and while that can be misconstrued
as rudeness at times those who know Mr
majors and work in the industry have
attested to his dedication to his craft
as well as his kindness now for those
unaware this is something that needs to
be explained and understood and this is
in regards to what method acting is and
it's really important for this case for
these accusations against him method
acting is when an actor basically
becomes the character that they are
playing meaning in their minds they
aren't playing a character they're not
playing a role they're not shooting a
movie they are the character themselves
and they never break out of character so
anytime they're on set in between scenes
on a break speaking to the crew speaking
to really anybody the director their
assistant they are still that character
they are not Jonathan Majors but they
are the character that Jonathan majors
has become but those are my own words
let's look into how the Nashville Film
Institute defines method acting on their
official website they State we have all
seen actors completely immerse
themselves in their characters to the
point where they transport us to another
time and place and for some of us that
that's why we go to the movies what is
method acting method acting is a
technique that performers employ to
empathize with the characters they are
portraying emotionally in this technique
the actor becomes the character and
frequently remains in the role for long
periods the actors are urged to feel the
true sentiments they require in each
scenario rather than compartmentalize
and fake them this can cause
psychological and behavioral changes for
as long as they are in the position the
website also does State the actor must
be ready to go through emotional trauma
if they opt for method acting so there
you have it these actors become the
characters kind of shedding their actor
skin and instead in their minds they are
that character and many many famous high
praised critically acclaimed actors do
this or have used method acting in the
past some famous ones are Daniel
Day-Lewis Robert De Niro Heath Ledger
Dustin Hoffman Al Pacino know Jim Carrey
some of the great ones but also at the
same time some of the actors that have
used method acting have suffered that
emotional trauma that the national Film
Institute spoke about like Heath Ledger
or Shia LaBeouf and I'm sure even the
ones I mentioned before have suffered
emotional trauma as well as it is a very
hard thing to do method acting but the
main point of explaining this is because
this is what Jonathan Major's team is
stating was the reason for the behavior
on set basically stating that anytime
Majors was on set he was completely
immersive with method acting so anytime
anyone talked to him he was the
character who wasn't Jonathan Majors but
he was the character that he was playing
so in any given situation or
conversation he was acting as the
character would he responded like he
thought the character would and for the
Sundance Film magazine dreams The
Producers allegedly warn production
members to stay away from Jonathan
Majors due to his method acting
techniques so they knew what was going
on they knew how Jonathan Majors was
they knew how he was becoming the
character and they knew how the
character was so in this statement
released to Indie wire Jonathan Majors
his lawyer and his whole team and him
essentially are stating these claims
about him behaving violently or
emotionally abusive on these sets were
him being a method actor and in some
cases like magazine dreams the entire
production the cast and the crew were
warned about how he was behaving because
he was method acting now obviously this
does not give him the right to Simply go
out and start abusing people or punching
people in the face which is not what
anybody is claiming he did but the point
is it doesn't give him the right to
Simply abuse people but this is a very
well known technique so when working
with a methan actor you have to realize
this is what is going on they are
responding to me the way a character
that they're playing would and this is
sort of a response to the people who
said they worked with him at Yale as
well because Jonathan majors has been an
immersive actor for some time now
including when he was studying it and
learning about it and yeah people have
said some bad things about method actors
before stating that they are just so
hard to work with in fact Will Smith had
a lot of things to say about Jared Leto
working with him in the suicide squad he
said that he never even really met Jared
Leto until way after the movie was done
and Jared Leto admitted that he went
full Joker he sent the cast members
gifts which weren't actually gifts but
he would send them dead rats he would
send them bullets and he did this
because he never broke character he
never went out of his character even in
his own personal life at his home yeah
we I got that Jared said we can't just
skip over that yeah yeah I want to use
condom what do you say what do you think
you know you say Jared has gone full
Joker Jared he went full Joker you know
and the rule generally is never go full
Joker never go full Joker but but he
went all why don't you go full joke you
never go down
so as crazy as it sounds actors do do
this and a lot of Great Performances
have come out of actors doing method
acting and this is a big refute from
majors's team because they are simply
stating he wasn't mean he was in
character he wasn't abusive he was
simply behaving as the character would
and in some cases the production did
warn the crew that that's how he is
that's what he's doing now again I'm
sure people can take it too far but that
is probably one of the biggest reasons
people have said that he's actually very
hard to work with and as his lawyer
stated everyone who has worked with Mr
Majors knows that he employs an
immersive methane act in style and while
that can be misconstrued as rudeness at
times those who know Mr majors and work
in the industry have attested to his
dedication to his craft as well as his
kindness and it is interesting that
nobody who's really worked with him
recently has come out and really said
anything about him Anthony Mackey was
the only person to come out and say
something who hasn't really worked with
him before and he just came out and
stated that he was innocent until proven
guilty so in response to the allegations
that Jonathan Majors was intimidating
and behaved violently and was rude on
sets and perhaps back in college when he
was studying film this is the response
to that he wasn't behaving rudely
according to his team he was simply
immersing himself as the character with
method acting so go ahead and let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below we will announce a
new giveaway winner tomorrow on July 3rd
but we are entering another giveaway for
the month of July so if you want to
enter for a chance to win an Xbox series
X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items all you gotta do subscribe
and leave a comment down below you can
also check out our patreon account our
Discord server and our website and of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well we'll link those
down below as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf